Dave: Introducing...
three time golden bib award champion.
Winner of the Hammy for Best Original Custard.
The Stuffed Face Magazine Man of the Year!
He was also Employee of the Month once at
a Denny's in 2006.
It's my honor to present to you...
CHEF BRIAN!!!
*cheering*
Brian: Hello friends.
And welcome to another fun filled episode
of The Wokking Dead.
I'm your new host, Brian.
Would you look at that.
I guess it's THYME to get cooking!
*rimshot*
Today's recipe comes from a user named CGruesCook.
He says, "we're gonna make some delicious
Bloody Sundaes!"
Cordon: RAUGH!
Darn right we are!
Dave: Who let Cordon on set?
Security?
Security?!
Cordon: They're not here Dave.
I gave them tickets to Dead Air on Ice!
Dave: We're not doing the show with you Cordon.
Get out!
Cordon: I'm not going anywhere.
Brian: I think it'd be fun to have a guest
host on the show.
Dave: He just tried to kill you!
Brian: I'm sure it was all in good fun.
Cordon: Yeah Dave!
Quit being a party pooper.
Dave: I'm just... know what?
This is unbelievable.
Cordon: Haha!
Cordon and Brian: WE ARE THE WOKKING DEAD!!!!
Brian: For this super COOL recipe, you're
gonna need the following items.
Ice cream, whipped cream, cherries, chocolate
and strawberry syrup and a banana.
Cordon: And... human blood!
*laugh track*
Cordon: What the fudge was that?
Brian: Very funny Cordon.
But we're gonna use this to chop up the banana.
Cordon: No!
NO!
You're doing it all wrong.
You have to do it like this!
Brian: Whoa!
Hold on Cordon.
Cordon: What?!
Brian: This is my show.
I think we ought to do it my way.
Cordon: What do you mean YOUR show?
It's called "The Wokking Dead" for Buddha's
sake.
Brian: I'll tell you what.
Since you're a guest on my show, we can each
make one.
You do yours your way, and I'll do mine my
way.
Cordon: UGH!
Fine.
Whatever.
But what do you say we make this a bit more
interesting?
We'll find a random person to judge our desserts.
And if I win, I get to stay on the show as
a co-host.
Brian: OK.
Cordon: Gimme that!
Brian: But if I win, you're off the show and
you sacrifice all your recipes to me to be
put in my new cookbook: Brian's Cookbook.
Cordon: Wait.
It's called Brian's Cookbook?
No bad pun?
No tagline?
Fine!
Whatever!
You've got yourself a deal, Chef Brian.
Brian: OK gang.
The first step for my sundae, as always, is
to wash your hands to get rid of those yucky
germs.
Cordon: Screw that!
I haven't washed my hands in years!
Brian: Now, just flatten out the top of your
ice cream.
Cordon: I like to scoop my ice cream into
a big eyeball like this.
Incidentally, this is a great tool for scooping
out someone's actual eyeball.
Brian: Next up, we're gonna add our two banana
slices.
This should add some aPEEL to your sundae.
Cordon: You should make like a banana and...
kill yourself Brian.
*rimshot*
Cordon: A real chef would dip their banana
slices in the chocolate like this, and place
it right here.
Then you can stab it in the eye with a toothpick.
Incidentally, toothpicks are great tools for
stabbing someone in the actual eye.
Brian: Now it's time to WHIP up some features.
Cordon: I like to whip my cream myself.
Incidentally, this is also a great tool for
torturing someone.
Where's Dave anyway?
Brian: I'm just gonna grab this--
bottle of--
Cordon: Your move Brian...
Brian: Let me just-- OW!
Shhhhhellfish.
That really hurt Cordon.
Cordon: Not as bad as it's gonna hurt when
you lose Brian!
I hope you've all placed your whips carefully.
Now, run the syrup down the ridges.
Gimme that!
Cordon: Perfect!
Brian: Now just cut a cherry in half.
Cordon: Gimme those.
Cordon: Now I like to add pure vanilla extract.
Even though it's vanilla ice cream already.
It's just so good.
Brian: I'm gonna add a bit of blood to finish
off my Bloody Sundae.
Cordon: No, you're doing it all wrong!
Gimme that.
You have to do it like this.
AHHHH!!!
Done!
Brian: Alrighty.
Wasn't that fun?
Cordon: I really realized over the course
of this episode, I hate you.
Brian: O... K...
I'm afraid that's all we have time for one
this episode, but tune in next time to see
who the winner is.
Cordon: And don't forget to vote!
Brian: Where would they do that?
Cordon: In the comments of course!!
And it's gonna be me you vote for.
Brian: As always, try these recipes in your
own kitchen.
Cordon: IN YOUR OWN HOME!
Brian and Cordon: Thanks for watching and
we'll see you next time!
Dave: I can't take this anymore.
Cordon has pissed me off for the last time.
I have to call in reinforcements.
Man on Phone: Reinforcements?
Dave: I have to call...
The FDA.